notre invité politique aujourd'hui c'est
ian brossât bonjour je vous remercie
beaucoup d'être avec nous est adjoint à
la maire de paris vous êtes porte parole
du parti communiste français vous êtes
avec nous pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représenté par
julien lécuyer de la voix du nord où
jean julien bonjour oriane bonjour
monsieur pour ça bonjour et on commence
par un débat qui refait surface
ian brossât c'est le débat sur la
vaccination obligatoire l'académie de
médecine elle s'est prononcée pour la
vaccination obligatoire pour certaines
professions y hier à l'issue du conseil
des ministres
gabriel atta le porte parole du
gouvernement il n'a pas vraiment fermé
la porte sur ce sujet disons toutefois
que ce n'était pas la priorité est ce
que pour vous il va falloir la rendre
obligatoire cette vaccination non et
pour tout vous dire je trouve cette
discussion un peu étrange dont je suis
pro vaccination est le parti communiste
par la voix de fabien roussel s'est
exprimée à de très nombreuses reprises
en faveur de la vaccination simplement
le constat que nous faisons aujourd'hui
c'est que beaucoup de gens qui
souhaitaient qui souhaitent se faire
vacciner n'ont pas pu se faire vacciner
donc on prend d'une certaine manière les
choses à l'envers prenait la situation
des enseignants
le choix fait par le gouvernement de ne
pas vacciner de manière prioritaire
les enseignants est un choix qui
interroge beaucoup d'entre eux auraient
voulu se faire vacciner beaucoup d'entre
eux faute de vaccination ont contracté
le virus certains parfois en sont
décédés dont je pense que la priorité
aujourd'hui c'est de faire monter en
puissance la vaccination est de
permettre à ceux nombreux qui veulent se
faire vacciner de se faire vacciner dans
l'est dans les délais les plus rapides
possibles la vaccination des enfants
l'académie de médecine la préconisent
parce que l'immunité ddd plus de 18 ans
ne suffira probablement pas est-ce que
vous pensez que c'est une bonne solution
je ne suis en tout cas absolument pas
fermé à l'idée qu'il faille vacciner les
enfants simplement pour l'instant
vaccinons les adultes je rappelle quand
même que aujourd'hui le taux de
couverture de la vaccination première et
deuxième dose c'est 14% de la population
quand ces 35 % en grande-bretagne et
c'est à dire que nous sommes aujourd'hui
encore considérablement en retard par
rapport à certains de nos voisins on a
même moins vacciner que l'espagne nous
sommes quand même la cinquième ou la
sixième puissance économique du monde 2
nous avons encore du retard continuons à
rattraper ce retard plutôt qu'à lancer
des débats qui sont au regard de la msa
presque là les doses harry la
vaccination sera ouverte à tous dès
lundi est ce que une fois que tout le
monde n'aura plus à vacciner tous ceux
qui le souhaitent si l'immunité
collective n'est pas atteinte en tout
cas le chiffre pour l'atteindre n'est
pas n'est pas remplie est ce que là il
faudra rendre la vaccination
je pense que nous n'en aurons pas besoin
pour une raison assez simple c'est que
au fur et à mesure on voit que les
français sont de plus en plus favorable
à la vaccination à la fois parce qu'ils
se sont aperçus des ravages de cette
épidémie et parce qu'il voit au fur et à
mesure autour d'eux que les gens qui se
sont fait vacciner se porte fort bien
donc continuons à vacciner augmentons le
rythme de vaccination et au final
l'adhésion des français augmentera elle
aussi autre question sur eux sur la
crise sanitaire vous êtes je crois
personnellement pour le pass sanitaires
pourtant les peaux les parlementaires
communistes eux s'y oppose et requiert
l'avis du conseil constitutionnel
ce que vous regrettez pas cette cette
opposition non je j'ai dit comme fabien
roussel d'ailleurs que je n'ai pas
d'hostilité de principe au pass
sanitaire simplement ce que je dis est
ce que disent d'ailleurs un certain
nombre de parlementaires c'est que là
aussi on prend le débat allant vers moi
je ne suis pas hostile opa sanitaire dès
lors qu'on permet à tous ceux qui
veulent se faire vacciner de se faire
vacciner
or aujourd'hui je le redis beaucoup de
ceux qui auraient adoré se faire
vacciner ces derniers mois n'ont pas pu
le faire parce que là c'est parce que ça
ian brossât la guérison plus tôt c'est
que plutôt que de lancer des tas de
débats commençons par augmenter le
rythme de vaccination disons quand même
la vérité la vérité c'est que la france
pendant des mois à vacciner à la vitesse
d'un escargot qui aurait perdu le sens
de l'orientation
on n'a pas vacciner rapidement
contrairement à d'autres alors certes le
rythme augmente un peu mais la priorité
aujourd'hui est sur le passage
on va pas les limites et il a lancé deux
passes tony
je pense que les parlementaires
communistes ont eu tout à fait raison de
souligner un certain nombre de problèmes
posés par ce dispositif est une fois de
plus le gouvernement ferait mieux de se
concentrer sur l'accélération du rythme
de vaccination plutôt que de lancer tous
les quatre matins des débats qui à mon
sens non pas de pertinence
c'est ce que la le passé à lutter c'est
pas nécessaire pour des confiné pour
couvrir certains lieux pour permettre
aux touristes aussi de revenir la clé au
rayonnement ci nie aujourd'hui c'est
d'augmenter le rythme de vaccination
c'est d'ailleurs pour vous oui et c'est
d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle nous
nous battons avec les parlementaires
communistes et avec fabien roussel pour
la levée des brevets pour faire en sorte
qu'on puisse produire massivement du
vaccin et du même coup vacciner
massivement or pour l'instant
certes le président de la république a
dit qu'il y était favorable
enfin je ne vois pas le grand bras de
fer lancé par emmanuel macron pour lever
les brevets et pour faire en sorte ou
encore dans ce débat là pour le coup ben
non les deux c'est ce qu'on a encore est
ce qu'on a encore besoin de ça bien sûr
qu'on a besoin de deux d'aborder ce
débat pour des raisons financières
parce qu'on le sait bien la question du
prix auquel nous achetons les doses est
une question essentielle derrière ce qui
se prépare c'est un véritable hold up
sur la sécurité sociale parce que comme
pfizer nous fera payer non plus 12 euros
non plus 15 euros non plus 25 euros mais
mais on nous parle parfois de plus de
100 euros la dose à ce moment là qui
payera ce sera la sécurité sociale et
notre sécurité sociale se retrouvera
ruiné parce que nous sommes dans la main
des big pharma dont kylie a nécessité à
lever les brevets comme le propose
fabien roussel puisqu'on parle de
dessous vous avez peut-être lu
l'interview des échos une interview de
bruno le maire et d'olivier dussopt un
nouveau projet de loi de finances
rectificative qui va être présenté un
mercredi 15 milliards supplémentaires de
mesures d'urgence de soutien aux
entreprises et aux secteurs en
difficulté
est-ce que vous avez l'impression que le
quoi qu'il en coûte se poursuit et ce
qui doit être la règle ce qu'il doit
s'arrêter comme le dit bruno le maire
ce que je vois surtout c'est que le
gouvernement multiplie les aides aux
entreprises
plus de 200 milliards d'euros des deux
entreprises tout additionné aide qui
systématiquement sont accordés sans
aucune espèce de conditions ni sociale
ni environnementale et c'est ça qui pose
question enfin vous avez quand même vu
là aussi les chiffres qui sont tombés
les entreprises du cac 40 cette année
enfin l'an dernier par dont on verser 51
milliards d'euros à leurs actionnaires
51e gyan mais là les 15 milliards 15
milliards de soutien aux entreprises
vous imaginez bien que ce n'est pas que
que les entreprises du gain du cac 40 et
son doit demander des conditions d'un
environnementale à des commerçants qui
dissertent cherche simplement à combler
leur déficit de leur chiffre d'affaires
les petites entreprises celles qui
véritablement souffre de la situation
depuis un an les commerçants notamment
méritent d'être aidés à l'évidence dans
munitions sous conditions sous
conditions toute aide doit être
conditionnée vous savez qu'en quelques
conditions les entoure les éditions
notamment de de maintien de l'emploi
ce qui me paraît évident que c'est quand
vous êtes chômeur aujourd'hui vous êtes
converger interdiction de vous est
conditionnée censier si vous recevez une
aide oui absolument mais lorsque vous
êtes chez votre entreprise absolument
lorsque vous êtes chômeur pour toucher
votre indemnité il ya un certain nombre
de conditions pourquoi est ce que quand
vous êtes une entreprise vous n'êtes
conditionnée à rien et par ailleurs je
le redis on parle des petites
entreprises et une fois de plus les
petites entreprises méritent d'être
soutenus les grosses entreprises les
entreprises du cac 40 qui ont bénéficié
du chômage partiel qui ont bénéficié des
deux massive et qui dans le même temps
ont versé des dividendes à leurs
actionnaires
est ce que c'est normal
est ce qu'il est normal qu'en pleine
crise les entreprises du cac 40 et
verser 51 milliards d'euros à leurs
actionnaires alors même d'ailleurs que
leur bénéfice cumulé ses 39 milliards
d'euros c'est à dire
rendez vous compte qu'elles ont puisé
dans leur trésorerie pour verser du fric
à leurs actionnaires
en même temps qu'elle touchait des aides
de l'état enfin on est où là et dans le
même temps l'état ne demande rien aucune
espèce de remboursement il ya quand même
un sujet il y à un sujet sur la
transparence de l'utilisation des fonds
publics en direction de ces gros son
sujet sujet malgré tout que les que les
états aborde puisque vous n'avez vous
avez un problème moment vu ce sujet
l'allemagne et la france suivant en cela
le président des états unis joe biden se
disent favorables désormais une taxation
d'au moins 15 % des profits des
multinationales est ce que ça va pas
quand même dans le bon sens oui ça va
dans le bon sens ça avance lentement
mais ça va effectivement dans le bon
sens parce que il y a une forme de
distorsion kiné qui n'est pas acceptable
entre ces multinationales et de deux
petites entreprises qui elles payent
leurs impôts rubis sur l'ongle donc oui
bien sûr ça va valoir l'elysée c'est un
camarade dubaï donne n'est pas un
camarade loin de là et joe biden n'est
pas n'est pas communiste
assurément ce que je pense en revanche
c'est que dans la période que nous
vivons le bon sens et communistes parce
que dans une période où les difficultés
sociales s'accumulent le bon sens et le
partage et c'est ce que prône le parti
communiste et c'est ce que prendra
fabien roussel dans cette campagne des
élections présidentielles un mot sur la
réforme de l'assurance chômage elle
entrera en vigueur le 1er juillet le
gouvernement sont montés maintenir le
cap resté droit dans ses bottes et vous
y opposer à cette réforme de l'assurance
chômage est ce que vous avez échoué à
faire plier le gouvernement
en tout cas une chose est sûre cette
réforme est une ignominie
quand on sait la situation des chômeurs
aujourd'hui d'abord plus de la moitié
des chômeurs ne touche rien et la moitié
l'autre moitié touche en moyenne 905
euros
et voilà un gouvernement une ministre
puisqu'il faut quand même la nommer
madame bornes qui décident de cette
réforme qui va se traduire par le fait
qu'à partir du 1er juillet plus d'un
million de personnes celles qui touchent
905 euros par mois en moyenne vont voir
leurs indemnités baissé de 17%
enfin vous vous rendez compte pas quand
on est ministre quand on est dans son
bureau et qu'on décide de prendre une
décision paraît enfin quelle mouche peu
peuple qu'est ce que j'allais faire
maintenant est ce que vous avez pris
acte du fait qu'elle entrera dans le
premier jeu non et je soutiens toutes
les mobilisations des syndicats qui qui
vise à faire échouer cette réforme
enfin ces commentaires monsieur nous
sommes non ça n'est jamais trop tard et
on ose elle est d'abord vous avez bien
vu que y compris sur la réforme des
retraites dont tout le monde nous disait
qu'elle était définitivement entériné
nous avons obtenu qu'elle ne le soit pas
et gmail surtout la crise sanitaire qui
a décidé ça seulement c'est aussi le nom
c'est aussi elle était pourtant on le
bien sûr les rares est sauf que le
gouvernement ne l'a pas remises en place
parce qu'ils savaient que s'ils la
mettait en place ce serait perçu comme
une provocation après la grosse
l'auditeur oui abondance dans ce comté
golan et signe avec la crise sanitaire
qui a empêché a eu au préalable la
mobilisation des salariés et la
mobilisation des syndicats pour alerter
sur le caractère catastrophique de cette
réforme croyait bien que le gouvernement
donc vous croyez que la révision de
l'assurance chômage pourra trouver le
même destin
je pense que cette réforme est tellement
indécente fayette 10 millions de pauvres
en france
est ce que ce gouvernement considère
qu'il n'y en a pas assez
parce que cette réforme disons le
clairement elle se traduira par le fait
qu'il y aura des pauvres supplémentaires
donc je le demande à madame board est ce
qu'il n'ya pas assez pauvres dans notre
pays est ce qu'il n'ya pas suffisamment
de gens qui attendent sur les fils
alimentaire du secours populaire et des
restos du coeur
enfin l es nés avant la honte madame
borno mais je vous le dis franchement
faire ça dans ce contexte là c'est une
monstruosité et quand je pense que ça se
dit de gauche
enfin je la connais mal à morne je les
ai connus quand elle travaillait à la
ville de paris sas dit gauche
enfin des gens qui ont 900 euros par
mois on va leur antre retiré 17 % de
leurs indemnités mais enfin quel est
l'objectif de cette réforme a par
pourrir la vie de gens qui ont déjà du
mal à vivre donc vraiment j invite le
gouvernement à y réfléchir à deux fois
et je pense que c'est irresponsable de
mettre en oeuvre une telle réforme dans
ce contexte on va parler d'un autre
sujet d'actualité sont les relations
entre police et justice
oui un autre sujet qui
qui divise la la gauche alors je vous
avouerai que moi j'ai pas bien saisi
fabien roussel votre votre candidat à la
présidentielle parce qu'il nous avait
donné une interview à la voix du nord le
9 mai pour déclarer qu'il n'y avait pas
besoin son sens de changer les lois pour
lutter contre l'insécurité
et puis patatras deux jours plus tard
face à jean-jacques bourdin il dit être
favorable à des sanctions plus lourdes
pour les attaques contre les détenteurs
de l'autorité publique
alors simple question le candidat
communiste s'est il a l'air du temps
sécuritaire d'abord il n'ya pas un air
du temps sécuritaire il ya une réalité
vécue par capa ni surenchère sécuritaire
à l'heure actuelle il ya une réalité
vécue par des millions de nos
concitoyens et je le dis comme élu d'un
arrondissement populaire qui est une
souffrance du fait d'un securid une
insécurité et et de faits de délinquance
qui sont insupportables
la sécurité ça n'est pas un fantasme
c'est une réalité vécue par des millions
de jeunes le conteste mais c'est de
savoir si sur quel pied veux danser fin
de fabien roussel se lisent plus de lois
plus de sanctions ou autant de sanctions
mais plus de moyens plus de moyens à
l'évidence et plus de sanctions
et bien sûr qu'il faut des sanctions et
d'ailleurs il faut plus de moyens pour
plus de prévention et plus de sanctions
plus de moyens ce n'est pas un esprit
cette contradiction entre deux jours en
deux jours deux jours près il n'ya pas
que ya une difficulté finalement pour le
parti communiste à se situer sur ce
terrain de la sécurité
aucune espèce de contradiction et je
fais le dis clairement mot parti
communiste nous voulons la sécurité pour
nos concitoyens et pour plus de sécurité
il faut un retour de l'état dans les
quartiers populaires parce que l'état y
a trop reculé et lorsque l'état recule
ce sont les mafias qui avancent donc je
vous le dis il faut plus de police
il faut plus de justice et il faut plus
de services de bill de manière générale
aux de police n'y a plus de police
nationale et nous proposons avec fabien
roussel une police nationale de
proximité avec 30000 hommes et femmes
qui soit chargée de la sécurité dans nos
quartiers et dans nos villages parce que
véritablement cette question de la
sécurité pourrit la vie pourrit la vie
dans un certain nombre de quartiers
populaires lorsque vous êtes une femme
que vous avez travaillé toute la journée
et que vous rentrez chez vous et vous
avez la trouille et quand je
10g des visages en tête je le dis ça
n'est pas acceptable et donc moi je
l'assumé
il faut plus de forces de sécurité dans
est-ce que pourtant vous soutenez la
police municipale à paris ce qui est là
aussi nous pas une forme de
contradiction non d'abord le parti
communiste ne s'est pas encore prononcé
sur cette question de la police
municipale à paris le débat a lieu la
semaine prochaine mais je le dis c'est
trop facile d'aller place soutiendrai
mon soutien le le le jusqu'à présent le
groupe communiste n'a jamais été
favorable à la police municipale
je ne le sais pas encore la décision
n'est pas prise et institutions et les
discussions se poursuit non mais j'en
termine c'est trop facile
c'est trop facile de se dégager
systématiquement sur les collectivités
locales le gouvernement l'a fait sur la
crise sanitaire
il le fait maintenant sur les questions
de sécurité en disant que ça relève des
collectivités locales est qu'elles n'ont
qu'à créer une police municipale c'est
quand même pas normal sur un sujet
régaliens que ce soit les collectivités
qui épongent derrière les insuffisances
du gouvernement le régalien
la sécurité c'est le rôle du
gouvernement et donc il est nécessaire
de créer des postes supplémentaires de
policiers un mot sur la polémique
on peut dire ça comme ça entre audrey
pulvar et et gérald darmanin vous la
connaissez bien voudrait pulvar elle est
dans l'équipe de hand algo ils se sont
tendu la main mutuellement tout cas
gérald darmanin lui a tendu la main il
n'a pas refusé
est ce que pour vous c'est une affaire
close désormais c'est une affaire close
je n'en sais rien ce qui est sûr c'est
que ça ne grandit pas le ministre de
l'intérieur et je n'ai pas bien compris
pourquoi gérald darmanin s'était lancé
dans une telle initiative tout à fait
ridicule et intempestives
on a encore le droit dans d'autres pays
d'avoir une opinion audrey pulvar a
exprimé une opinion
on est pour ou on est contre m'enfin ça
n'a pas à ceux à se régler devant les
tribunaux et par ailleurs je n'aime pas
cette forme de judiciarisation de la vie
politique on fait de la politique on
doit assumer le débat on doit assumer le
désaccord ce qu'est le propre de la vie
politique et puis après c'est aux
français de se faire un avis ce matin
gérard larcher le président du sénat ils
parlent de faute de carre du fait que
gérald darmanin et envisager une plainte
conte audrey pulvar vous priez partage
arrive à raison et il a parfaitement
raison et et je partage totalement
l'opinion de gérard larcher sur ce sujet
en tout cas on va parler paris oui
toujours de paris restons en effet dans
le domaine de la sécurité alors hein
un dossier qui est très embêtant pour la
mairie les fumeurs de crack qui
empoisonne le quotidien des riverains de
la place stalingrad dans le 19e alors
que vous avez essayé de résoudre la
situation en lait en ouvrant un parc
juste à côté le jardin d'eole pour
essayer de aussi de soulager le ce
quartier mais les tensions restent et
les riverains du jardin désormais ce se
plaignent comment on peut résoudre cette
situation
d'abord cette situation elle est
effectivement préoccupantes c'est la
préfecture qui a décidé de de déménager
d'une certaine manière les usagers de
crack qui était à stalingrad pour les
envoyer au jardin d'eole à la frontière
du xviiie et du 19e arrondissement de
paris
cette situation elle est insupportable
elle dure depuis longtemps on ne pourra
la résoudre qu'en marchant sur nos sur
nos deux jambes d'une certaine manière
d'une part la répression contre les
trafics et donc le rôle de la police et
d'autre part les soins les soins parce
que on a affaire à des gens qui
effectivement ont des noms des
addictions et qu'il faut faire sortir de
ce cycle infernal dans lequel ils sont
c'est la raison pour laquelle il va bien
falloir créer des salles de repos des
salles de consommation encadrée je ne
souhaite pas d'ailleurs qu'on le fasse
systématiquement dans les mêmes
arrondissements n'y a pas de raison que
ce soit systématiquement les quartiers
les plus populaires qu'ils soient
mobilisés enfin en tout cas il n'y a que
comme ça qu'on sens il faut éviter le
regroupement et essayer d'envoyer cesser
ces gens ces données vers d'autres
cendre pour lui je vous le dis le
nord-est parisien n'a pas vocation à
être systématiquement mobiliser pour
faire preuve de solidarité à la place de
tous les autres ça va en matière
d'accueil des toxicomanes
ces arrondissements là ces quartiers là
ont déjà beaucoup fait et donc il est
parfois temps de mobiliser d'autres
vivres aux riverains que bientôt ce sera
résolu
j'aimerais pouvoir leur dire sauf que ça
relève de la préfecture de police et
comme je n'aime pas mentir je ne le
dirai pas en ces termes je peux pas
m'engager pour les autres en revanche ce
que je vous dis c'est que ça assez duré
et et qu'on ne peut pas en permanence
demandé aux habitants des quartiers
populaires de tout supporter il supporte
déjà beaucoup il supporte déjà
suffisamment et donc il faut partager un
peu un mot sur les éboueurs qu'on a vu
en colère
cette semaine les éboueurs de paris en
cause la réforme de la transformation de
la fonction publique qui va augmenter
leur temps de travail puisque cette
réforme met fin en dérogation aux 35
heures est ce que vous comprenez cette
colère est à ce qu'un accord vous semble
possible avec baby bien sûr que je la
comprends et par ailleurs en
l'occurrence il s'agit de l'application
d'une loi ce pas une décision de la
municipalité et toutes les municipalités
sont en ce moment confrontés au même
problème
moi je trouve cette loi très très
injuste parce que je comprends bien les
gens regardent ça de loin il se dit ça
après tout ils pourraient travailler un
peu davantage enfin on a affaire à des
personnels je pense aux éboueurs je
pense aux aux égoutiers qu'on a une
espérance de vie très très très
inférieurs à la moyenne des salariés
ce sont des gens qu'on a beaucoup salué
pendant le premier confinement qu'on a
beaucoup applaudi et au fond le
remerciement qu'on leur fait aujourd'hui
c'est de leur dire il faut travailler
davantage
je trouve ça assez injuste ce sont des
professions difficile et donc je
comprends complètement la colère
s'exprime à paris elle s'exprime
d'ailleurs dans d'autres endroits de jeu
tant qu'il ya des discussions je crois
qu'il ya des discussions qui doivent se
poursuivre avec l'adjoint en charge des
ressources humaines
je souhaite effectivement que nous
parvenions à un accord bien sûr et à ce
qu'on tienne compte de la difficulté de
ces métiers qui doivent être saluées
mais il nous reste un peu de ton pas
beaucoup pour parler des régionales on
va parler d'abord de l'ile-de-france et
de ce sondage ifop qui montre que
valérie pécresse est loin devant à 33%
derrière c'est jordan bardella à 16%
laurent saint martin pour la majorité
présidentielle à 15 et les trois listes
de gauche qui sont peu dans un mouchoir
de poche entre 10 et 11 courses en 10 %
c'est la barre de qualification pour le
second tour
s4 où vous divisez vous ne risquez pas
de vous éliminer ce qui est sûr c'est
que le le premier tour traduit un
éclatement de la gauche mais enfin elle
savait puisque
il ya trois listes de gauche différentes
moi je soutiens comme les communistes
les analystes tirée par clémentine
autain si ça se passe comme ça ça va
est ce que je souhaite surtout c'est
qu'au deuxième tour on puisse se
rassembler à des éliminations au premier
tour pour une telle histoire je ne le
pense pas tout cas j invite les
électeurs à voter massivement pour
clémentine autain ce qui est la
meilleure garantie qu'il n'y ait pas
d'élimination en revanche ce qui est sûr
c'est que au deuxième tour si nous nous
rassemblons la victoire est possible
parce que au final nous ne sommes pas si
loin de valérie pécresse et donc la
victoire
elle est à portée de main si on est
capable les analystes disent souvent que
c'est pas c'est l'addition l'addition
des voix ne se fait pas forcément
automatisés ont parfois les analystes
trompe
oui parce que c'était l'autre notre
nouvelle d'hier que le et un sondage qui
donne rassemblement national en tête de
10 points en région paca est à 50/50 en
cas de duel au second tour avec le
président sortant renaud muselier est
aussi la liste d'union delà de la gauche
sur troisième des urnes au premier tour
c'est quand même une forte probabilité
ce que vous appellerez au retrait à
voter pour renaud muselier d'abord avant
le deuxième tour est le premier jeu je
me garderai bien de considérer que
l'élection est passée donc laissons
d'abord le premier tour se dérouler et
je n'ai pas envie de me placer dans
cette perspective là pour le reste
puisque vous me posez la question et ça
ne vaut pas que pour le sud ça vaut de
manière générale aux sur le parti
communiste a toujours pris ses
responsabilités face à l'extrême droite
et je ne crois pas et d'ailleurs vous le
savez bien
en tant que journaliste à la voix du
nord le parti communiste n'a jamais
laissé passer l'extrême droite vous
l'avez vu d'ailleurs dernière mission
régionale pas fait mais est ce que vous
regrettez pas que d'autres formations
n'est pas cette cette transparence
autour de cela si enfin en tout cas pour
ce qui nous concerne nous nous avons
toujours été très clair sur ce sujet de
l'extrême droite il n'y a pas de raison
que nous fassions autre chose que ce que
nous avons toujours fait merci beaucoup
merci d'avoir été notre invité ce matin
la une de la voix du nord pavillon bleu
bien plus qu'un label pour touristes oui
justement voilà mais si vous n'aimez pas
vie en bleu dont
mais c'est très bien et c'est à dire
dans la voix du nord aujourd'hui merci
messieurs
[Musique]